what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
bowl and branch there's nothing more
important than a good night's sleep
bowling branch knows it takes more than
a good mattress you got to have nice
sheets
bowling brand sheets are ultra soft plus
they're 100 organic
and sustainably produced let me explain
something to you
these sheets are tremendous they're cool
at night no matter how warm it is out no
matter how warm it is in the room but
anyway my room is always freezing anyway
these sheets are beautiful they're light
and they're soft they're just tremendous
you sleep like a baby
get ready for this the bowling branch
guarantee enjoy any product worry three
worry free for 30 nights to experience
the best sheets you've ever felt choose
bowling branch you could try them worry
free for 30 nights with free shipping
and returns
the joint listeners get an exclusive 15
off the first set of sheets with promo
code joey
at bowl and branch
bowling branch bowlingbranch.com
again that's bowlin branch
dot com b-o-l-l-b-r-a-n-c-h
[Music]
[Applause]
dot com
use promo code joey the joint is also
brought to you by
draftkings the nfl is back [__] and
you're getting paid like dandy don
meredith
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the nfl is giving new
players a hell of an offer for the first
week only you ready
bet one dollar on any game
and cash 200
in free bets
instantly no matter what you heard me
right here your uncle joey's telling you
i'm handing you free [__] guitars
draftkings is giving all new players
200 bucks and free bets when you place a
dollar bet on any game
one
this week not this week when the season
premieres
labor day week i think it's august 11th
around there
september 11th
september 12th around there so we're
giving you 200 bucks and free bets when
you place a dollar bet on any week one
game
bet a dollar and get 200 put the [__]
hummus down let's kick up the [__]
onion dip and take advantage of this
limited time offer
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now download sportsbook app not
the fantasy sportsbook app use promo
code joey to receive
203 bets when you place a dollar bet on
any week one game that's promo code joey
j-o-e-y
to get your 200 and free bets instantly
it's the official sports betting partner
the nfl i got to tell you something you
got to be 21 or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only
this deal only applies to new customers
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details now if you got a gambling
problem call 1-800 gambler if you're in
indiana call
would it but if you're [__] straight
oh [__]
let's get down to making some [__]
guitars with the draftking sportsbook
app i'm going to win you some guinness
we're going to open up with 200 the
joint is also brought to you by
[Music]
on it let me tell you something about on
it
without them i wouldn't [__] be and
now
they're introducing alpha brain focus
shots
they come in peach and tropical flavors
unfucking believable and don't forget on
it has a new alpha brain black label
it's a premium
refined formula that promotes speed
and more focus
for extreme productivity who gives you
that uncle joey does with on it if you
don't like alpha brain or if you don't
think alpha brain can help you they have
a money back guarantee
if you don't like the product you can
still keep it and you'll get your money
back
a guarantee like that is made when a
product is exceptional so do me a favor
go to honda.com
look at what they have the fine line of
supplements from the alpha brain to
shroom tech
they they're just great
i mean they just have great products
the alpha brain i'll tell you what i was
a little sluggish for a couple weeks i
went on this new alpha brain black label
and i'm feeling a lot better i'm
sleeping better and my [__] i'm ready
to stab a [__] so do me a favor
go to honor.com right now preston church
or joey and get 10 off your first order
delivered to your house i hope you order
the new alpha brain black label
it's gonna [__] give you a new
feeling you're gonna feel like going in
there and just smacking somebody with
your dick
so down get that go to on it.com right
now and order alpha brain black [__]
label supercharged formula mental
process and focus for extreme
productivity you stay in the [__]
zone without it use promo code joey a
church let's get this [__] podcast
started [__]
it's monday morning
august the 23rd let's do this
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 23rd of august
i hope you had a great weekend i hope
you had a great [__] week last week
we did i had a good [__] week last
week i had a couple breakthroughs
doctors you know the whole [__] thing
now this week i will be out of town
shooting a tv show i'm [__] excited
about that i get a little insurance next
year just in case i need new [__]
glasses or new teeth or whatever the
[__] it is you got to work a certain
amount of quarters to qualify for
insurance supposedly they're not using
residuals no more it's a brain [__] i
don't give a [__] i'm just looking to
work i'm not getting rich i'm just going
to go work see some people
say hello and be [__] uh you know
still be out there what the [__] am i
doing here just sitting around these are
the worst two weeks of august
to be here it's gonna be humid nobody's
around people are [__] traveling it's
back to school time you know people are
depressed [__] it i'm going on a road
trip i'm gonna eat some food i'm gonna
smoke some reefer and i'm gonna enjoy my
time
with my [__] family you know what i'm
saying i have a great time with them
this last week we went to see [__]
grease
at the rec center we left after 20
minutes the sound sucked
so we got the [__] out of there plus the
mosquitoes were eating this out
friday we went to a [__] bonfire
saturday we went to two parties we went
to a party i gotta tell you it was great
to see this guy
you know it was uh i went to two parties
first i had to go to freehold
and then i had to go back up north
to a different outdoor party and [__] it
was raining you know we had to catch
whatever we could but i saw a guy that
made me [__] laugh so hard i thought
back to 84.
new years of 84 we're in a bar
we got a couple lines in this we got a
[__] gorilla biscuit in us
it's me stinky
my man roger god rest his soul and
fernie a bunch of us hanging out but it
was
our unique click and this kid came in
his name was john he looked a little
[__] perturbed it wasn't new year's
eve yet it was like uh
uh probably 10 45. the ball was a little
cl quiet still this was a quiet bar we
were there for a [__] reason this kid
walks in he's all [__] flabbergasted
he goes listen
i don't know what to say
my father just got jumped down at this
uh taxi place
on [__] 32nd street it was close to
my mother's bar so i knew exactly what
he was talking about he goes we got to
go down there and [__] [__] them up
now i got a couple cocktails in me i got
a gorilla biscuit
i got a [__] coke i got a couple
lines in me i'm in no mood to go in
hand-to-hand combat with anybody
that's the worst time to get yourself
involved in a [__] altercation
but my friends were like let's go you
know let's go down there [__] help
him out and i'm like oh [__]
so we go down there we get in the car
the kid gets in his car
and we all go down to union city we
[__] parked the car and
the taxi cab stand it was a cab stand
like in good fellas it's a it's a big
good fella's week [__] uh it was a
cab stand and it had like
sun shield on the [__] glass
so you really couldn't see in
you could see people standing there but
you really couldn't see in
so we pull up
we get out of the car and the guy john
he goes listen this is my dad
i just need you guys for backup let me
go in there
and do the cleanup first and if you if i
things get danged
you guys come in
i said all right no problem you know i'm
a little [__] up i'm not even talking
probably i'm just making noise
you know whatever the [__] i'm doing
so the kid has a bat with him
and we're like what the [__] is this guy
gonna do he's got a bat with him
and he walks through the door
he opens the [__] door we you know
you could actually see him walking in
he closes the door
and you could see him
approaching
like three or four guys that are in
there
were like what the [__] he doing i'll
send you here
you just hear a [__] like you could
[__] hear it like a bang
and all of a sudden our buddy comes out
of the taxi stand holding on to his head
and he's like [__] bleeding you know
not a lot he's just bleeding a little
bit but you could see his little [__]
discombobulated
and he's like help help my friend goes
to him who hit you mickey mental because
he was [__] bleeding from the head
and [__] i reminded him of this on
saturday and he just went [__] pale
he didn't like it too much he didn't
like the memory of being brought up but
hey
when i said it to him he the joke just
went flat like remember when you got hit
in the head with the bat and roger asked
you who are you mickey mantle and he's
like
i don't know
it [__] happened [__]
but anyway what i wanted just to open up
a little something for you guys
just to get you going just to see what i
got to deal with on the [__] weekends
i got to see these people now and
retrace the [__]
nah he's like i don't remember anyway
[__] uh
the beauty of it is i wanted to talk to
you guys about something the other day i
was looking at my daughter you know
and we're having a good time here we
really are she's got new friends she's
she you know goes to kickboxing she does
all this [__]
she had a great time in camp friday i
went to she told me thursday night
at the [__] greece movie
she goes dad one of the counselors there
he really likes you in one of the movies
or some [__] can you come in and say
hello to them like absolutely you know
it's the last day of camp i didn't want
to i've been to the camp before i just
never went in there
because i didn't want them to go oh
that's her dad you know whatever she's
having a great summer on her own she
want to [__] another medal on friday for
some athletic award you know she's
having all that [__] on her own i didn't
want to go in there and then go oh
that's uncle joey's daughter i didn't
want that so
i didn't go in there i just wanted to
see what she would do on her own merit
and she did [__] great you know
pictures they had a [__] carnival
last week
this was a hell of a [__] camp big
pool couple [__] pools field houses
they don't have to bring lunch my wife
didn't have to make lunch all summer she
was ecstatic about that they had ice
cream bars
you know it's all about the [__] kids
here and that wasn't even the really
good camp
that was like a median camp frog's neck
is like when they [__] smoke
cigarettes and they have tea parties and
[__] and crumpets it's it's it's [__]
amazing you could go from a basic camp
here where it's just them playing on
[__]
on concrete to like camps with raps and
they take them helicopter rides i didn't
want to do all that
i just wanted her swimming and doing
athletics they they play
every game there in the world
every [__] day with football
basketball she learned how to throw
football we're outside throwing a
[__] football it's a great little
[__] camp
so i go in and i know my daughter i'm
like she's gonna be [__] she's so
emotional
she [__] fell in love with one of the
counselors or whatever i i know my
daughter i just know her so
yes uh friday at four my wife goes i'm
gonna pick her up are you coming i go
absolutely in fact i wanted to shower
and got all duded up
that's the type of [__] i am
when i came out of the shower i was
yelling for my wife and she's not
answering like she [__] left without
me and i came out she was on the couch
we went down there
[__] beautiful camp trees everywhere
you know i didn't say no anything to
anybody when you walk in you got to put
your mask on
so i guess people couldn't tell whatever
so i walked in
and i went over the way we have together
and sure enough
she was one of the girl counselors the
girl counselor was crying mercy was
crying it was [__] tremendous
mercy's like i don't want to go but then
we had to get the girl's number we're
going to use her as a babysitter but as
we were walking out the guy that runs
the camp goes uncle joey
and i i look at him he goes how you
doing my name is john i run the camp
your daughter was great this summer we
didn't know until this week that she was
your daughter we started laughing our
asses off great [__] people you know
and she was a little upset we went and
got a little slice of pizza at
[__] carlos
and then uh we went to the [__]
bonfire thing but i was looking at her
you know and i'm like wow
she's a way different kid than i was at
that age at eight i already knew about
[__] blow jobs and [__]
people getting stabbed i saw my
stepfather shoot a guy and [__] a
santoria party my daughter doesn't have
any of that i mean
and that's how i like it you know the
other day some guy hit me up you know
joey we're not saying that we don't like
what you're doing but
you know you should [__] smoke during
the album of the week and just so we
could smoke with you listen guys
listen
listen i told you once i told you a
thousand times my daughter lives in this
house i didn't get a studio because of
what's going on in the world right now
and time will get one
but for right now i can't smoke in this
house this is her house and i can't
disrespect her and if you need to watch
a podcast or you need to see an album of
the week on patreon
with me smoking because you feel like
we're smoking together i think it's time
for you to put a white jacket on and go
get some [__] help
do you think when i look at snoop dogg
smoking i'm like oh i'm smoking with
snoop dogg that's a problem guy that's a
a craziness type [__] that's never gonna
[__] happen get it together i got a
thousand videos on [__] youtube of me
smoking that was the past this is the
[__] present so and this is why i do
it because i don't want her to ever come
to me and go what's that smell
i've smelt that before in the house this
is her house
so i got to give it to her you know what
i'm saying
i live here that's it but it's her
[__] house i live here and i pay the
bills but it's a [__] house so
you got to understand where the [__] i'm
coming from
so i'm looking out of the day and i'm
like what is she
you know i mean she's
she's great
i'm really happy that she didn't have to
go through what i went through as a kid
i'm really hap like i got friends that
call me hey we want to invite you to
this restaurant [__] you there's no kids
there and there's alcohol i don't want
to see my daughter drinking [__]
people drinking [__] up or acting
like jerk off that's not what i want to
do because that's what i did as a child
i was in a [__] ball looking at and
they were irritating the [__] out of me
back then when i was a [__] 10. so
you can't imagine what they do now i
don't want to be in a [__] ball i
haven't wanted to be in a boss since
1980 [__] four so
so i was looking at him like you know
what's crazy about her she doesn't have
the fear that i had
i had fear when i was a kid i wasn't a
tough strong kid when i was her age
i had fear
ever since the time i left from new york
city the other day on instagram i posted
a picture of my mother's house it was
for sale in 2018
and i was in the neighborhood i went to
bring flowers at the cemetery and i went
by the house like i always do the check
on it and it was for sale i took a
picture of the [__] thing to send it
to my wife
and then me and my wife were talking
when i got back to california she's like
do you want to buy them like they want
365 for it and you're gonna have to sink
two or three hundred thousand in there
just to modernize it just so the house
could be in 2021 the house is still 1960
[__] eight
you know if you've seen it so
we just said no i don't want to live
there but i thought about it afterward
let me tell you something from the age
of 10
to the age of 16
i was never settled in that house i
don't know if you've ever lived in a
house
that you won't settle in all i remember
is waking up one day
on
you know
[__] riverside drive and 89th street
overlooking the hudson river
that's where i first remember living and
then after about six months
the apartment got raided one day for
numbers
and my mother thought the apartment was
spooked so we moved to 205 west 88th
street and i lived at 205 west 88 since
i was 5 until i was 10 years old with no
[__] problems at all i loved living
there
i watched [__] scary movies
that never affected me i watched the
exorcist at 10
never affected me i think i slept with
the lights on for a few weeks but it
never really i could deal with all that
[__]
when i moved to 35 15 given that terrace
something happened to me as soon as i
walked in that [__] house something
did not feel right i usually base my
life on energies if i don't feel right
doing something
i won't do it again and it all started
with that [__] house that house
had a creepy [__] effect to it we
moved in that house
in may of 73
probably
two or three weeks after i beat up
sister heisent at sacred heart school
for boys it was probably right around
that time
that my mom got the house in jersey and
that's when we decided we're not gonna
go to that school no more i had
chickenpox that week the mets were
playing the [__] uh the cincinnati
reds i actually went to the met game
with the [__] chicken pox i just put
makeup over my [__] little
pimples on my head and i went to the
game i saw [__]
pete rose beat up butter harrison i went
to two games it was two home games
but i still remember moving to that
house
i didn't like it i didn't like the kids
outside
i didn't like the house
i didn't like the [__] yard it was an
above-the-ground pool i wasn't crazy
about
but that wasn't what was i wasn't crazy
of that house
the energy inside the house
was not [__]
me at all
you know at first when we moved in you
know you have the yard you don't have a
yard living in new york city you know
the the attraction was the yard you know
i would go out to the yard and jump in
the [__] pool it was summertime and
we moved in it was like april may so
shortly after the pool opened and we
could swim and [__] you know i put up a
basketball court but the ground
back there was pavers
it was like
18-inch pavers so they weren't connected
so when you dribble the ball the ball
would [__] go everywhere else because
there wasn't a ground there was pavers
but again that's not the reason what
made me
the first summer the first probably
eight weeks was great in that house
and there was
one two bedrooms with a closet
uh room and a bathroom on the second
floor and then there was a third floor
attic that was refinished and it was
beautiful
it was cool as [__] they had like
paintings on the wall like a big
brush went around the [__] wall and
they crisscrossed i think the room was
yellow they had a great window [__]
strong as [__] air conditioner the
closet was a walk-in closet in the attic
and over on the side there was like a
stand for shoes
well i took that apart and [__] i took
that i lifted the [__] thing i busted
it all
and i discovered like a little hiding
space i used to actually go in there as
a little kid put the cover and make
believe like there was a that wall was
ending and i was downstairs in the
basement drinking like tang and [__] i
swear to [__] god my ma when you're a
single child you have a tremendous
imagination so i would go in there the
whole thing
it was great it was a little paradise up
in my [__] attic
but shortly after i moved in there
i started hearing [__]
i just started hearing [__]
you know
i just
something wasn't right about that
[__] house and i still remember being
like mercy's age
and
one night
before i went to this was after i was
already like i had gone to catholic
school
for third grade to sacred heart school
for boys and that was a boarding school
where you went to all [__] week and
then you came back thursday friday
saturday
so i'll never forget one of my first
weekends at boarding school i came home
you know everything was great went to
the bar
probably went to a movie my mom brought
me home at three with my stepdad
we sat downstairs and [__] for a
while i went up to the [__] attic
and my parents went to bed my mom went
to bed and some point in the night
i can't tell you what i felt
i felt like
somebody had grabbed my leg oh i pulled
on my leg it was the weirdest [__]
feeling i know joey you're [__] crazy
i'll tell you what i felt you know i
felt something i felt something and when
i turned to see what it was
i kind of was uh alarmed
and i made like a noise like ah like
something like that
and i just saw something and heard
something
i and here's the crazy thing
that after it went down
my mother and stepfather came out of
their room to ask what just happened
we heard something really weird i go i
don't know i was half [__] asleep
and i felt something grabbed my [__]
leg
and when i turned i was startled i made
like a noise they heard the noise
but they also heard the stairs like
something was wrong with the stairs like
somebody had gone down the stairs
so they're like what the [__] was that
you know i'm like i don't know but
whatever the [__] it is i'm not staying
up here no more and they're like you got
to stamp them that's the night that juan
gave me his gun with a silencer
and they go sleep with this and if you
see a ghost just shoot it and i'm like
okay like i was like okay i'm like
there was no [__] i don't know what it
guys i don't know what it was
but there was an energy in that house
that just didn't [__] feel right
and i went away to catholic school i
came back on the weekends you know i
would stay there
i would stay at my godmother's house i
would always stay different places on
the weekends
so i didn't have to deal with whatever
was in that house anymore
until
i got thrown out of catholic school
then i had a deal with whatever was in
that [__] house
once i got thrown out of catholic school
i went back i signed up in mckinley
the balzanos [__] call mine beat up
uh
bernie robson's father once i was in the
neighborhood i was very happy
but something happened
right in the beginning of the sixth
grade again
by this time i wasn't i transferred all
my clothes and everything as i was
getting older when i got back from
catholic school i took the room next to
my mother's i felt a little safer
i said whatever happened in the third
grade happened you know whatever maybe
i don't know maybe i had one two [__]
many blueberry brandies at the bar
because i would sneak them when i was
like eight or nine
but who the [__] knows you know i'm not
here to [__] say that there's a ghost
or whatever but we'll give it another
try we'll give it another [__] try
i'm a little bigger now i can handle
myself now i'm a little stronger you
know i just beat the [__] out of a nun
i'm ready to take over the [__] world
here so
we transferred into mckinley
i think i was in mckinley
i think a month
elapsed in those days i would play
whatever the [__] i was doing from three
to six three to seven and then about
seven i'd go up to my mom's bar i go to
the new moon chinese restaurant
on 29th and bergen line i'd eat dinner
whatever the [__] or cuban food or a
sandwich from hernandez
and then i would walk home i would walk
down the hill and
go to given that terrace and i'd go home
my mother would stay at the bar my
stepfather would stay at the bar
and i'd basically be alone till three in
the [__] morning no big deal i was
11. i was a big boy
i could [__] handle it
i think after a month
every time i would [__] turn the
lights off in my room and turn the tv
off
i would hear this [__] on the
[__] stairs
people coming up it was an old house i
mean it wasn't that old of a house
if it was 1973 when me we moved in i
think the house got built in 53 54 or
something like that
after the orphanage fire i'm giving out
terrace
so i really don't know how old it was
but man at night
once i put my [__] pillow down i put
my head on my pillow it was like there
was a [__] party in my house i would
hear people going up and down the stairs
[__] coming from the attic i would have
to call my mother i think one night i
called the [__] cops
the cops came and after about a week of
that [__] i was like [__] this
i'm not living here no more so i
started in the sixth grade
i moved out of my house i don't know if
you guys even heard this [__] story
in the sixth grade i pretty basically
moved out of my house
and i had two different places i'd stay
at i'd stay at 26th and central
at my uh
my friend eva's house my buddy
jose torres his mother had a house on
26th and central
2614 central avenue and i'd stay there
there was a his sister lived there lucy
his sister ellie lived there me and lucy
were tight in the mornings i wake up and
go get a [__] bag of zeppeli's i go
get a stick of [__] italian bread and
a whole stick of hotel bar butter and a
32 ounce coca-cola and i'd bring it back
over there me and lucy would eat the
[__] whole
bag of [__] bread and i'd eat the
zepplies on the way to mckinley i had a
[__] system jack i was on i was on
fire up there in union city and i loved
it i didn't have to i would only go home
after school to get clothes
for the next day and i would go to
karate do my whole life go to my mom's
bar but i would end up on 26th street or
i would stay on 22nd and central by my
friend my cousin julio rodriguez he owns
anaconda
jiu-jitsu in north bergen and west new
york if you're looking for a jiu jitsu
school i might as well give him a plug
he's a good dude he's a great [__]
teacher
he's a hegan machado black belt but i'd
stay with him
and his mom
a wilder and his brother guillo [__]
you know so i would walk to north bergen
from 22nd street i did not like that
[__] house at all
my mom would beg me to come back i would
still see my mom and i'd still see my
stepfather was still part of their life
but when it came to sleep i just would
not [__] go down there
it took me
i didn't move back into 35 15 to maybe
middle of seventh grade
the year i got left back
so i moved out of my [__] house
basically for a year and a [__] half
and then i got a girl from the north
bergen and it's tough to tell your
girlfriend that you're scared of
sleeping in your [__] house
when you're in the 7th grade because you
look like a [__]
so i started living there again
sometimes during the week i would sleep
out
and chucky mcbreen's house or something
you know
or one of my other friends house
whitey's house or mario diaz's house or
anthony balzano's house if things got
too danger at night i would [__] you
know little by little
it was like i was you know just working
myself back into the [__] house
but i always thought that house
and that neighborhood were [__]
creepy as [__] and if i go down there
now i spoke about it a couple weeks ago
on here when you go down there now
just the neighborhood is dead
and it bothered me for years like
i didn't know what the [__] was going on
there i used to put a glass of water i
used to put earplugs in at night
so i wouldn't hear the [__] haunting
as i called it it was just a [__]
haunting
oh yeah it was going on but not
i think i was sleeping heavier
and i wasn't really dealing with it i
would put earplugs on
you know so i went back the year i got
left back you know once i started
giving my mom a problem at school like
there was a the teacher called her in
one time so she was like enough with
sleeping out you got to start sleeping
back in your house
what did i pay for this [__] house
for and i was petrified of that [__]
house
you know so many weird [__] things
happen in that house like
i think the weirdest thing that i ever
saw was the night
the chick knocked on my door beat up
like that's never happened in my life
again i've been in [__] horrible
situations
in horrible places but at the age of 12
for a woman who's
barely [__] had clothes on her
husband ripped her clothes off
and she had blood coming from everywhere
and knocked on the door that's just a
spooky [__] thing like it took me a
while
like i'm like this [__] neighborhood
never stops
this chick just knocked on my [__]
door you know bleeding and as we opened
the door we had to rush her in and her
husband was running up the block with a
[__] knife and my stepdad had to get
a [__] gun to wave the guy down this
is my life and [__] the seventh grade
you know it was [__] crazy and then
my mother ended up letting some friend
of hers tati a great he was a great
friend i loved him with all my art
you know do some santeria [__] in there
and the house really went to [__]
then my mother and stepfather broke up
my mother hit him in the head with a
[__] saint like a statue of the
virgin mary just hit him in the head
when he was sleeping he got up there was
blood everywhere i mean the things that
happened in that [__] house
another night i was a sophomore in high
school maybe two weeks before my mother
died we almost lit that house on fire
one night i mean there was almost a
[__] battle in that house
we were in the [__] house my mother
was in florida selling her property down
there
she had this property on mia on uh miami
international airport
i don't even know what happened with
that [__] but anyway we were having i
said my mom's gone i'm starting to get
popular let me have a [__] party at
my [__] house
so i got like a keg you know we did the
right thing i had a downstairs i had a
garage
you know i had a sub basement i had a
garage and i had the living room i could
have everybody up there my living room
was a little creepy because i had the
six foot saint
in the living room of saint lazaro and i
had you know it was just a [__]
creepy living room but i could contain
them
in the garage and downstairs in the
basement these girls [__] showed up
and this one girl in particular was a
little [__] loose you know what i'm
talking about
and we're [__] sophomores and this
girl's a senior
and uh
my one buddy who i was telling you about
a couple of weeks ago louie
had a thing going with that girl she was
like a senior you know so
we were sophomores
i knew louie since the seventh grade at
mckinley he was my boy you know i was
telling you this story a couple weeks
ago
so louie takes the girl upstairs to my
attic
and my other friend steve has got a girl
in my bedroom
i don't give a [__] i'm just as long as
i don't go in my mom's bedroom i lock my
mom's door i'm standing downstairs in
the kitchen talking with this kid chris
that we used to call the red devil and
these other guys eggs and all these
other guys and we're just having a
conversation nobody else knew
beside chris
that my man louie was upstairs with the
girl and my other man steve was upstairs
with a different girl nobody [__]
knew
me and chris knew
we're sitting down it's probably 12 30
at night the party cleared out
we're just talking [__] i don't even
think we're high
and all sudden i hear somebody coming up
the garage stairs
and this is kid eddie with another kid
and two other [__] gorillas
and the kid eddie his girlfriend was the
chick upstairs of louie
and you could start you know i
that other guy it was a great built
house
it was a [__] solid [__] house i
used to jump off there was two sets of
stairs i used to jump off the [__]
stairs down to the floor that [__]
floor stayed tip top magoo the way it
was
forever i had been jumping off that
[__] thing since i was 10 my mother
would tell me stop one day you're gonna
go to the [__] floor i didn't give a
[__] i would jump off their jump off
they'd jump off there
so we're sitting in the [__] in the
kitchen it was a dining area there was a
dining area there was a living room and
then there was like [__] tv and all
this [__] big downstairs we're just
sitting there talking [__] and the saint
is right here saying lazarus saint is
right here he's six foot five he's got
crutches and [__] real crutches
so one thing leads to another and eddie
and his buddies come up and they're like
we're looking for this girl like
i have no idea where the [__] she's at
you know she was here earlier
but she left you know and he goes no no
no no no
she's here you know she's got to be here
we're like dog what are the only ones
here you hear anybody [__] else
and the kid's like well
then you won't mind me looking around
like oh that's not going to happen this
is my mother's house
and that's not going to [__] happen
and the kid's like yeah it is gonna
[__] happen and as he started walking
towards me
chris was a [__]
animal
this kid was a [__] street urchin
he [__] took one of the crutches from
saint lazaro
like a [__] five-foot crutch and he
goes
if you take another step i'm gonna break
this over your [__] head
i'm like holy [__]
this is gonna go down in my living room
because he had three gorillas with him
and he goes if you go past this i'm
gonna break this over your head
and then i got up and took the other
[__] cast and i go looks like you're
gonna get hit in the head twice
and every other guy that was in that
kitchen with me that night i forget
their names
i'll tell you what everybo we were gonna
take these [__] down right in
that thing this is gonna turn
into goodfellas when they're kicking
poor [__] uh bobby bats and all that
[__] this is just gonna turn into this
was not good
and now i start to hear
the bed upstairs
the rock and rack and rack and rack and
rack and run and everybody's like
looking around and we're like
like making noises and [__] and we're
like you're not gonna [__] pass this
so we're gonna hit you in the [__]
head with the [__] crutch
the kid sat day he's like i don't know
what the [__] he goes you guys are tough
guys tonight what if we came down there
with more people then we'll make a
[__] call and we'll get more [__]
people
you're not coming in your house my house
listen to what you're saying
you're saying that you want to walk in
my house and search it you know who the
[__] are you
you know and now i was a little scared
of this guy eddie and his [__]
friends
but at that point i wasn't scared
anymore who the [__] you know once
you're right you're right who the [__]
are you to come in my [__] house get
the [__] out of here we just told get
the [__] out
get the [__] out it will break your
[__] head
and chris led the [__] charge till
this day i still love him i don't know
where he is i see him on facebook my
friend he was red-headed kid so my
friend used to call him the red devil
so we [__] they left and we were like
that was a [__] close one
you know monday we had a deal with [__]
i think the kid said something to me at
school monday that he was keeping my eye
on me but we never even discussed it
again it moved on but that was how crazy
that [__] house was and then
after my stepdad left the [__] house
the house just had this feeling that
even when my stepdad lived in it
have you ever listened to the end of
pink floyd dogs
when he goes you're a stranger at home
you know and all that [__]
that's what i felt like
after 1978 right before i graduated high
school we didn't really have a home it
was just three people living together as
much as i loved my my my mom and my mom
love me i don't want you to get me wrong
we loved each other but we were three
people that were living doing our own
thing
and we weren't even eating dinner i was
eating dinner at the [__] bar
so once my stepfather left and my mom
let dottie do the [__] thing there a
house really want this [__]
you know a house went the [__] [__]
my mom was gambling
the house was just a bad luck house
you ever have that where you're just
like this is
i i don't know the house just wasn't one
of my favorites you know when i moved
into this house i'm like huh
this has the spirit that that house had
no it doesn't not even [__] close
that house was just dark
it was dark even when you had the lights
on is that a good way of explaining it
to you like when i think back to going
in and out of that house
i see it in black and white
like i see the rest of my life in color
but i see that in black and white that
that's why i didn't [__] like that
[__] place
and the kill like i always knew
something wasn't right like i always
knew something wasn't right
i didn't know
that that house wasn't gonna end
the right way like i would love to tell
you i knew
but i just knew that house was just not
right and there were two things that
finally cemented that that [__] house
wasn't right
the night i came around the corner and
found my mother on the [__] floor
with bruises on her arm
and she was dead as disco and i mean
you know when you find somebody dead in
the house
in that house the for sale sign goes up
the next day
there's no reason to stay there there's
no reason there was a debt in that house
you know it's like the
the judge that got shot a husband and
kid got shot in east brunswick
uh last year you know
they sold the house you can't live in a
house with death in it you know pick up
the floor take all the blood out of the
[__] house
you know redo it so there's no blood in
the house not like you're wiping up the
floor with blood you're not leaving
blood on the floor you're taking up the
wood you're taking up everything and you
get and then redo a new [__] house my
friend his uh sister-in-law killed
herself
in the house on christmas day that
[__] house was for sale new year's
day i mean you just don't stay there
once i found
my mother on the floor it was confirmed
to me
that
i i didn't have a solid [__] house
but this
is where it gets
even weirder for you
are you ready for this
my mother [__] dies we take it to the
funeral paula you know
the whole thing
we're about to do the week of
the wake and [__] we're all at the house
eating dinner whatever we're eating like
a snack after we identified the body or
whatever
i don't know particular what day this
came
but it did happen
we were all sitting in the living room
my mother was dead and i was feeling
[__] jaded
i was confirmed that this house where i
lived at was [__] spooked i just
found my mother on the floor
and there's a knock on the [__] door
they all look at me you're gonna answer
me i guess i'm gonna [__] answer it
so i go over to the door answering this
is nice white couple
and uh
she's like oh how you doing we didn't
mean to bother you were you guys doing
something no no no what's going on and
she i never saw this woman before
i never saw this man before and they
just started telling me that they lived
in the neighborhood
and they that the people who lived they
wanted to see who moved into the house
because they knew the people who lived
there previously blah blah blah blah
blah blah and i'm like
looking at like i'm not you know i don't
know what this lady's talking about
and she's like we used to live on the
block and we became friends with the
people who lived here
and you've done such a nice job with the
house the front of the house you know my
mom fixed it when we got in
she put the bushes in and all this [__]
and she go you know ladies like whoever
lives here did a great job with the
house we love the windows oh my god we
knew the previous owner rested so and
i'm like
rest is so
what are you [__] talking about
and a lady goes you didn't
i don't know anything i'm just a [__]
16 year old kid
what do i know she goes well we lived
here
from the 60s and the owner here was a
nice guy and he had a nice family
but one day they found him in the garage
he [__] killed himself
and
it was like [__]
like the twilight zone
i was like i [__] knew it
i knew this [__] house was [__]
haunted
and the lady's like yeah he killed
himself in the garage he didn't hang
himself he closed the garage door and
left the exhaust on and you know
that's how he [__] died and i'm like
holy [__]
we talked for a little while
and then
she went off the porch and all my
beliefs have been confirmed
i knew there was something weird in that
[__] house
you know i hate to say it was a haunted
house but there was something
beside me in that [__] house and it
was not
happy it wasn't a happy house like when
i walk in here i'm smiling and [__]
that house didn't bring the happiness
out of you it brought uh
i don't know it brought like this
[__] confusion
over my life that's what it did i and
ever since i moved out of the house i've
never ever ever experience that again
or feel like in that that way like i
would take showers the door open
you know it was it got to me the fear
the real feel like there was
something dark in that house and that
day it was
you know i was happy that i knew it my
mother
didn't she didn't believe me this house
can't be [__] awesome i'm like listen
man
and i saw something when i was a kid one
time when i was a kid like four
in manhattan we lived on when we when we
lived on riverside drive
the hallway of the kitchen the kitchen
like if you look out the kitchen you
know it was uh you could see a window
over there a window over there and a
window over there and you know whatever
one night oh anyway you're gonna think
i'm crazy i was not getting high when i
was four years old so i don't want you
to go joey you were [__] hot but one
night i heard like a guy
in
the hallway outside the kitchen i
remember looking out and seeing like a
shadow
and telling my mom my mom was like they
couldn't have been it was impossible but
i saw something
and i remember my mom looking at me
weird and looking out the window
and going yeah maybe you did [__] you
know i i don't know for sure
i don't you know i don't know how i felt
back then but i remember that i felt
something
sort of like i felt
when i moved into 35-15 given that
terrace and then to make it all [__]
come together
and i could invite you guys to look it
up too
if you
you know like i told you to look up the
superman of cuba and it's a long read
in that same vein
there's an article if you google it on
the give and add terrorist mysteries
it's called something like that given
that terrorists lower north bergen you
could find it if you google it i'm gonna
try to google it
today and put it up on uh twitter and
patreon whatever for you guys
and it's an article about that area down
there that
there was an orphanage on given that
terrace it was called she was called
marry given art that was the [__]
name
she had the orphanage and there was a
fire one night
and all those kids were killed in fact
if you went up the woods
on giving that terrorist terrace
you still saw the the foundation of the
orphanage and the wall was black from
the [__] fire oh just look up given
that orphanage
fire and it'll give you oh i mean it is
just
it's like 30 40 minute read
about that area and how haunted
it [__] is
i'm telling you guys that [__] area
is haunted i sit here i stand here and i
tell you that i have never felt that
ooky or creepy before in my life that
whole area down there from walking past
that cemetery i'll tell you two stories
then we'll wrap it up
they say that there's have been
witnesses and i heard that when i lived
down there that there was a lady that
would walk on union turnpike
or liberty avenue they said a lot of
people saw
dressed like with lace and walking with
a candle
did i see it no because i wouldn't be
here right now i'd be in guatemala
[__] hiding if i saw like a lady
walking
they say you see it like [__] gliding
and if you read the article you'll go
joey okay it's not you
there's like 20 eyewitnesses that have
seen that lady
walking around and they say that it's
mary gibbonart
that's walking around but then
it takes you back to nineteen
like 30 or something this is the
spookiest [__] story ever that
cemetery where my mother's buried it's
called the weehawken cemetery it's been
there since jesus left chicago it's been
there for a long [__] time i told you
not that cemetery but there's another
cemetery that
blends into weehawken
that i took a [__] in the night that
freddie prince got [__]
that died
that i never forget when i was [__]
on it the only reason why i [__] on the
body you know me i'm a [__] catholic
and i respect spirits
but that [__] died like in 1830.
there was nothing left in that box it
was in fact his tombstone was like bent
over and it was rugged looking and all
the tombstones in the area were like
crosses that the [__] cross had been
taken down like there was just a stick
it was 100 [__] 50 years old at the
[__] time
but that cemetery has been there for
such a long time in that same married
given out article
you'll read a story about across the
street from that [__] cemetery there
was a row of houses there still is and
one night rock started coming out of
that cemetery and breaking all the
windows on that hill going down
so the neighbors came out to see what
the [__] was going on and they were
getting hit with rocks and [__] so they
all called the police
and the police
[__] circled
the cemetery
circled it like a police [__] thing
because i think it was after three
nights they kept throwing rocks they
circled the cemetery and they went
through that cemetery inch by inch
and they never found the [__] thing
that was the same cemetery i was gonna
jump i did jump the fence
and tried to [__] unbury my mom new
year's eve
79 but that's a different podcast we'll
get to that some other time
but it all has it on there so if you
look up
married uh given odd
terrorist
orphanage
if you google it you'll come upon that
article
and you'll read it you'll see that the
[__] i'm telling you is not [__]
[__]
i felt it in my [__] soul it was a
creepy [__] feeling and i never want
to feel it again and that's what my
daughter
will never [__] have that creepy
scary feeling i never got there anywhere
else i never got it at my mother's bar
i never got it at other people's homes i
just got it when i walked
in that [__] house on when i walked
on that block
it felt weird and over the years i've
heard other things
that have come out on that you know
charles court that it was just
the orphanage was on both streets
so and there's people that lived
in the last house have a friend that's
named grace
she lives in tonkinton new jersey
uh
her house is on the top of giving that
terrace
and her mother lived there and her
grandmother lived there
and she told me once after my mother
died we were talking about this same
story
and she said that the people that owned
her house
said that for years after the
the fire at the orphanage
that at night they would hear kids
yelling from back there
like kids that were eight nine seven
yelling from the orphanage so that [__]
ran to the neighborhood for [__]
years you know
i wanted to tell you this story because
i put the picture up on instagram my
mother's house
a lot of people wondered why i'd put it
up i'd put it up to tell you this story
so if you go to my instagram matt
flavors world
you could see the house it doesn't look
haunted it just looks like a regular
house
but when i look at it now
it looks
like a [__] house that's spooky
and the thing that scares me the most
about this [__] house is that i
called it i just did not know
that uh
that it was gonna scare it's funny
because the people who bought the house
there used to be a bathroom window next
to the door
so if you rang the doorbell my mom could
look out the bathroom window and if it
was jehovah witnesses
she would get hot water and lower the
upper window and throw hot water the
jehovah witnesses but they put bricks up
on that window obviously whoever bought
the house put bricks up
they [__] up the bushes that my mother
put in there and the bushes that are
missing if you go to instagram and look
the bushes that are missing where the
bushes were won used to hide his gun and
his [__] knife outside
uh
that's my podcast for today that's uncle
joey's joint i just wanted to get that
story out of the way because i put up
the house
i put the house up i put a picture of my
cat up and i put up a picture two slices
of roma pizza and the house got like a
thousand [__] comments and i'm like
what the [__] and everybody wants me to
buy the house turn it into a dispensary
let me tell you something i thought
about buying that house and i was like
there's no way this is happening not i
thought about it for like a day i'm like
i could live in north bergen
you know i could [__] get that house
it could be modern as [__]
but i said no no no because whatever
lives in the house
i guarantee it's still [__] there and
that's my podcast for the week
that's uncle joey's joint
i hope you enjoyed this little monday
morning little [__] positive story
about haunted homes
and that's it laughing gas
is still in [__] stock it's back in
stock last week it's selling off the
[__] shelves
get there the big launch comes and what
joe told me was
this batch they got on friday
is better than the original [__] bats
they had last month it's gonna get
stronger and stronger
so if you're in the california area
stop by [__] ice cream shop
and pick up
laughing gas or any other one of the
ziki [__] products
that tickles your [__] fancy i got no
dates
i got nothing coming up except the
sopranos on october 1st
every day we're getting closer to the
release of this movie i'm watching the
episodes with my wife as many as we can
at night we try to watch one at night
we're on season three it is what it is i
love you [__] with all my heart
i'll be out of town this week taping
uh
stay black and i'll be back next monday
the 30th of [__] august oh
we'll be back wednesday what are we
[__] talking about we got a guest for
you too [__] stay black and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
all right i want to thank you guys
for watching the show today i hope you
got entertained by my spooky [__]
story
i've been dying to tell you this story
for a few weeks now that i put the
picture about be easy but real quick i
want to talk to you
a word from our sponsors the joint is
brought to you by
on it let me tell you something i've
been with on it for 10 years maybe i
love their products
from the shroom tech the shroom tech
immune but the alpha brain really does
it for me and now they're introducing
the focus shots which come in tropical
flavors and peach flavor and
they're introducing the black label
alpha brain it's a supercharged formula
it'll get your [__] brain firing the
gaba [__] firing you'll be [__]
tip top magoo reading books from other
languages speaking russian backwards
that's what alpha brain does for you but
it all starts with you going honest.com
right now
and looking at the fine set of
supplements they have
the beef jerky that
they're just great they listen i can say
it for two hours and talk to you about
on it and all the great things they've
done for me from the shroom tech immune
to the shroom tech sport but right now
we're talking about alpha brain the
black label and the focus shot give him
a shot
pressing code joey or church and get 10
off
delivered right to your [__]
crib
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings listen the nfl is back and
you're getting [__] and paid
draftking sportsbook is the official
sports betting partner of the nfl giving
all new players a hell of an offer for
this week
bet one dollar on any
football game and you're gonna cash 200
bucks and free bets i'm doing the same
for you in college football
whether it's college or pro football
you're gonna get if it's if you're a new
player
i'm gonna either give you a hundred
bucks and free credits for college
football or 200 for the nfl instantly no
matter what you heard me the [__] right
free money draftkings is giving all new
players 200 bucks and free bets when you
place a dollar bet on any week one game
put the [__] hummus down
take your [__] balls out and head to
draftkings sportsbook app right now and
check out their great promotions and
daily odd boost plus they got a casino
that's [__] tremendous blackjack
poker [__] roulette wheel but it
starts with you
make every game a big game with same
game [__] paulies that's what else
they got going on over at draftkings but
again it starts with you
download the draftking sportsbook app
not fantasy
sportsbook use promo code joey to
receive 203 bets when you place a dollar
bet on any week one game that's promo
code joey to get 203 bets instantly for
limited time only at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nfl new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling problem you got to call 1-800
gamble
if you're in indiana it's 1 809 with it
but if you're straight
download the draftking sportsbook app
and win some [__] guitars this is the
way to make some nice [__] dorae me
this season getting ready for the
holidays download the draftking
sportsbook app use promo code joey
listen
you're not going to believe what i got
here i got bowling brand sheets she like
joey [__] sheets really these sheets
are soft smooth and comfortable i got my
bed looking sharp with the new natural
colored sheets there's nothing more
important than a good night's sleep
bowling branch knows it takes more than
just a good mattress you gotta have nice
sheets bowling brand sheets are ultra
soft plus they're 100 organic and
sustainably produced
i love them they're cool they're light
they're buttery soft and they're
lightweight perfect for all seasons they
come in a variety of colors every size
from twin up to california king people
always ask me joey you always have
dick problems or gambling
ads you never have nothing for me to get
my parents anymore nothing here it is
nice bowling brand sheets here's
something special to help you sleep
bowling brand sheeps are made by
craftsmen who earn a fair living wage
these workers earn their pay and respect
they deserve
all the bowling brands products are made
using safe and fair
conditions
the bowling branch guarantee enjoy any
product worry free for 30 nights
you can't beat that to experience the
best sheets you've ever felt choose
bowling branch you could try them worry
free for 30 nights with free shipping
and returns
the listeners
to the joint get exclusive
15 off your first set of sheets with
promo code joey at bowling branch that's
bowling branch b-o-l-l
branch b-r-a-n-c-h
dot com
promo code joey
the joint is also brought to you by
onyx oh we said on it already right who
the [__] knows on it.com
they got a new alpha brain focus shot
that's gonna put [__] hair in your
[__] go to honor.com right now press
encode joey or church
and get 10 percent off delivered right
to your house i want to thank
bowling branch i want to thank on it and
i want to thank
[__] draftkings
sportsbook app for sponsoring us have a
great monday thank you for supporting
the joint thank you for supporting
patreon and we'll see you wednesday tip
top [__] magoo
stay black have a great monday
[Music]
you